لعب سويسرا يعتذر لجماهير الكاميرون قناع
سوني يظهر في المدرجات ومن هي صديقته
ايرلينج هالاند هذا الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعون على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
في لقطه غير معتدى في المباريات والبطوله
الدوليه رفض بريلان بولو لاعب منتخب
سويسرا
في مرمى الكاميرون في بطوله كاس العالم
ورفض الاحتفال بسبب اصول الكاميرونيه
مع والدته وهو بعمر السادس بعد انفصال
والديه
رغم كل ما حدث هل نعرف مدرب المنتخب
الكاميروني اللاعب امبولو على اهدافه في
مرمى منتخب بلاده مضيفا بانه يعرف امبول
منذ فتره وهو فخور لانه سجل هدفا في كاس
العالم ولو انه كان في شباك الكاميرون
[موسيقى]
وبعد الاصابه التي تعرض لها على مستوى
الوجه ارتدي نجم كوريا الجنوبيه
خلال فتره التحضيرات التي سبقت كاس العالم
وخلال مباراه اوروغواي ايضا وفي مدرجه
الملعب
ظهر بعضا من مشجعين كوريا وهم يرتدون
القناعذات وربما هو من جلب الحظ السعيد
الكوريين الذين ارغم اوروغواي على التعادل
يبدو ان النجم مانشستر سيتي والغائب عن
المونديال يعيشوا قصه حب مع لعبه كره
القدم
وتعرف عليها خلال فتره تواجدهم في نادي
بيراميد اندرويجي حيث بدء مسيرته الكرويه
واضاف صديق مقرب
وصديق الاجازه الصيفيه الماضيه في ماربيا
الاسبانيه